Speaker 1: All right.
Let's hear from a few more people.
We take calls via discord on the Friday show
David Pakman dot com slash discord.
It's completely free.
Completely free.
Let's go to.
Oh, I don't know.
Let's go to Brodie from Dallas.
Brodie, what's going on?
Speaker 5: Hey, David.
I have been doing well.
Speaker 1: I actually have a bone to pick
with you, I have to say.
Speaker 5: All right.
You know, when you.
Speaker 1: When you call in, you do these
beautiful calls, sometimes sort of esoteric
topics, but you're respectful and you're kind
and all these things.
But then it seems like you're plaguing our
discord and subreddit with kind of strange
attacks on me and on the show is that are
there to Brody's so to speak.
Speaker 5: I don't think there are to Brody's.
I think the latest thing that might have plagued
your Reddit was the show about the show.
Speaker 1: What was that?
Speaker 5: That was the David Pakman show.
Show.
Oh, my God.
A show about the show that encourages people
to subscribe.
Speaker 1: Well, that sounds good.
I don't know.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Every show we talk about the benefits of membership
and making sure that they support your show.
Speaker 1: Hard to be against that.
Well, what's on your mind today, Brody?
Speaker 5: I was actually thinking about a
interview I heard with Ezra Klein a while
back, talking about if we are entering an
era of post persuasion, politics, meaning
that so many people seem to be subject to
asymmetrical polarization or a stronger level
of polarization.
And I wanted to note in your observation,
because you've been in the game for a long
time, do you see the era of politics that
we are in now in terms of retail politics,
electoral politics?
Do you see us moving or are we already in
an area where it's all about registering,
cultivating and turning out a base?
Or do you see that there is still room for
persuasion on a broader level?
Speaker 1: I think it's mostly the former
and there is some of the latter.
I mean, I think you're starting to get these
smaller and smaller you.
You know, one of the genius things that Trump
did and I'm not even saying that he did it
on purpose, it just happened, is that he reached
people who had not been paying attention to
politics in any real way.
So they didn't even realize that they were
being lied to, that Trump's campaign promises
were impossible, that they were being propagandized
and on and on and on.
So what was genius about it was they completely
uncritically were just like, Oh, Trump, Oh
yeah, I'm voting for Trump.
And they were insulated from any kind of critical
thought.
And that's why when the Access Hollywood tape
came out, it didn't make a difference in all
these different things.
Increasingly, to win, you have to find those
groups of people that have not yet become
asymmetrically rattled, radicalize the way
that you're pointing out, or just asymmetrically
sort of devoted to one side or the other.
And Trump, Trump was able to do that.
So I think that it's a and it's an important
observation and it's an accurate one.
Speaker 5: And just as a quick follow up to
that, do you think that the current infrastructure
and the current messaging that the broader
Democratic Party and candidates have is capable
of fulfilling the the mission there, I guess,
that you outlined in terms of being able to
find folks that are able to be persuaded and
create a media ecosystem that promotes that
has.
Speaker 1: I mean, not so far.
So far, they've failed on two fronts.
One, they've failed to properly fund the effort
to create that ecosystem.
And number two, they failed to identify a
contingent of the half of the country that
doesn't vote, that could be sort of assembled
as a voting bloc and activated.
So so far, they've not proven they can do
it.
Speaker 5: Awesom